Well, thank you everyone for joining us here
on Thursday afternoon,
uh, where we're going to
be here to talk to you from SEM to SOC
building an AI native
security in the cloud with AWS.
I am Jen Reed. I'm a worldwide principal
security SA and I have with me
today. Hi, um, I'm
Manoj. Uh, I'm a product manager in the NextGen
SIM team and I lead the data in injure strategy.
Namab Solomon, uh, solution architect
to CrowdStrike for our AWS partnership.
All right. And so today what we're
here to talk about, um, we're gonna start
with just a little refresher for
those of you who may not be aware,
uh, what CrowdStrikes Falcon NextGen
SIM is.
Then we're going to dig a little bit deeper and I'll
come back and tell you guys about NextGen SIM
4. AWS
and what that all entails and then we will
follow that up with the Marketplace
play as you go which Rob will talk
a little bit about at the end.
Throughout this presentation we're gonna have a few
demos, um, that we're going to
show to you guys so you can understand how all of this
works
and so without further ado I'm gonna
turn it over to Manosh.
Thanks Jen
Hello, everyone, uh, pretty excited here
to actually share some insights on
some cool innovations that we have done in Exchange
SEM specifically for AWS customers.
So I'll be going to the details, uh, as
Jen mentioned.
Uh, but before that, let's actually start
by talking about some statistics from
our global threat report.
Uh, AI is the flavor of
the season. Everybody talks about AI. AI is
changing everything around us
for the better.
But at the same time, it is also
enabling adversaries to actually
improve their game.
So,
this particular threat report gives us some
key insights that I want to actually gain
your attention towards.
So let's start
with the first aspect, which is speed.
So as for the for the report
that we had this year,
the breakout time that takes, the
amount of time the user actually the
threat actor
takes to
gain access and breakout
is under 48 minutes,
and it's reduced from 56 minutes from last
year. And what
we observed in one of our customers
was
the user was able to execute this, uh,
the threat actor was able to actually break out
in under 51 seconds, that
is less than 1 minute, and most of
the organization actually need take
more time than that to actually respond
to a normal alert.
Next
is about stealth.
Most of these threat actors are now become
more sneaky. They are very hard
to detect.
And what we observed is that
81% of all the
the threat
and the breaches
were done through without any malware. So
gone are the times when we would actually use
the malware signatures and the files, hashes and
everything else, the traditional way of detecting
users are. Actually relying, the threat
actors are actually relying on
using
phishing and sophisticated mechanisms
to gain credential access,
some, let's say cloud admin
access, and somehow figure a way to actually
run manual
operations to gain persistence in the environment.
They are no more using malware. They're using
actually on keyboard manual
operations and legitimate tools to actually gain
access. Another
important aspect is sophistication.
So AI is another tool that they're leveraging,
and what we have observed is state actors,
state sponsored threat actors like famous
Colima actually are using to up
their game.
For example, they had.
Attacked 320 organizations
in one year and they have doubled the
number of phishing
campaigns that they are doing in the last.
The last few months
and we have seen that the cloud attack
itself has increased by 136%.
So what does this actually tell us?
That
AI is actually enabling these
threat actors to become faster,
difficult to detect, and more sophisticated
to identify.
So we need to use AI to actually up our
game and use it to actually defend
against these attackers.
So before we go into the details of how
falcon connection SIM would help with the exact
problem that I just mentioned, let's understand
how these threat actors actually behave. I'm assuming
most of you are familiar with this,
but just for uh knowledge purpose,
let's go through an exercise.
So in this case, we're talking about
a threat actor, scattered spider. Many of you may
be aware of it,
and we have been tracking this threat actor for a
while. What they,
what they prefer to do is use phishing
to actually gain initial access.
They somehow uh uh get access
of a, let's say cloud admin user,
use that to actually infiltrate into the
management or the control plane.
And then execute commands, for example, to
create uh a
new user, create a new VM,
uh, and then actually create, uh,
for example, download tools um
like RMM tools which are very legitimate
and then create persistence and create a backdoor
entry to exploit further,
let's say through ransomware attacks or to, to
do data exfiltration.
So they actually move across your
environment very quickly.
So that actually requires, so what is the problem
that we see here?
If you have to actually defend against these attacks,
you need visibility across multiple
domains.
You need visibility into your endpoints, into your
cloud, your identity, and other areas
within your organization
to actually defend properly.
And that's not
something that traditional SIMs and
tools that exist in the market are capable of.
So to summarize, AI definitely
is improving our life day to day,
making it much more easier, but it is also
enabling the adversaries to
uh gain access into our environment and
become more sophisticated.
So we keep asking this question,
and whenever we especially talk to our customers,
do your existing tools have the
necessary capabilities to address this challenge?
So whenever we have this conversation, we actually
identify and we come across
common scenarios and common frustrations
which we hear over and over again. First,
it is too, too many different tools that they
have to manage. They do not have a unified platform.
They need to actually access multiple tools and
make it work.
That means the users are spending a lot of time
figuring out uh how to
access the tools, how to integrate them.
So fragmentation is an exact problem.
Too many,
too many uh false positives,
too much noise to actually uh uh
analyze and figure out the true positives. It's
uh taking a lot, a toll on the
security analyst.
Again, response actions are too delayed.
They do not have necessarily the mechanisms
to act at the speed at which
these threat actors are performing.
So let's understand how
NextGen SIM is evolving to
actually address these challenges.
So
So the first, uh,
generally the question that I keep asking, SIM is not
a new technology, it has been there for decades. I have been
in the SIM space for over 15 years now,
and it has evolved, definitely.
So the question that I keep getting is what's
different about Falcon Nexgen SIM
versus the traditional SIMs that exist in the market.
And the first answer that I generally give is
a unified platform. Traditional SIMs
actually consider detection
and response as two separate functions
generally executed by two different tools
altogether,
whereas Falconnection SIM is a true
platform where it provides one single
workspace for detection,
investigation, and response. It does not differentiate
with it.
It truly
operationalized security operations or centralizes
it and unifies it.
So let's understand how this is actually achieved.
So
I'm not sure how I I think I saw
at least 50+ hands
of existing CrowdStrike customers, so you most probably
would have your endpoint solutions
deployed.
So with traditional SIMs,
one of the key challenges that you need to
perform is move all your endpoint data
and your identity data into a third party SIM.
You have to export the data.
That's not needed with an exchange SIM. It's a true platform.
Even if you're Falcon Insight or Endpoint
Solution, you have the SIM capabilities built
into the platform.
Second, uh, it actually can
respond immediately using the sensors.
You don't, you can actually block uh
a
a ransomware attack
rather than actually detecting it later once the harm
is done, or you could actually block a brute
force attack using the sensor
instead of detecting it after multiple days.
Plus we have a fusion workflow uh
powered by AI which allows you to automate
most of the response actions powered by
Charlotte which provides agentic workflows,
autonomous response, and automated
triage.
I'll go into the details of this in the next coming slides.
So the first important aspect of the takeaway
is a unified platform.
It's not a standalone single solution
or a siloed solution. It's a platform for
Falcon. Sorry,
Falcon, it's a uh platform
uh solution in every Falcon module.
So let's go into more details. The next
important question that I keep uh
um asked more often is what
exact data should I bring in
to actually get the coverage?
And our answer always is you need the data
that you need to actually
do your uh basically stop breaches.
You just need that right amount of data.
So that is a core principle where we differentiate
ourselves from other SIMs.
Instead of actually mandating
and ingesting logs indiscriminately,
our focus is on getting the most
important data set so that you can actually
stop your breaches.
Now what do I mean by that?
So with Falcon
platform,
We out of the box provide coverage in terms
of threat intelligence,
exposure,
endpoint, cloud,
identity, and IoT.
They are already available without any additional
cost. We also provide a mechanism
inside NextGen SIM which allows you to seamlessly
ingest third-party data through out of the box
integrations which we call as connectors,
passes,
and we now acquired a new data ingestion
pipeline, which allows you to stream real-time
data into NextGen SIM.
So instead of actually
asking the users to ingest
uh indiscriminately, our focus is
making sure that you bring the right data
and augment already available data
inside Falcon platform.
So that's another core principle where we differentiate
ourselves from other SIMs.
The third,
AI. AI is an uh
uh is a, I would say a tool that we use
inside Falcon platform at every step.
We have a workflow designed for
analysts
so that they can actually perform detection,
investigation and response in, in a very efficient
manner. So let's
understand how this actually happens.
The whole journey for a for an
analyst starts from analyzing
the uh uh the appropriate alerts. How do
they do that?
We have out of the box machine learning algorithms
which allows us to risk score
any given alert, assign it, and
surface it for the analyst to actually
focusing, focus on the right
high priority alerts that he needs to work on
instead of actually working across all the
sea of noise that he is provided.
So that and then again, um
AI
provides uh again, Charlotte AI
enables automated triaging
so that additional information
and appropriate insights is provided
for the user so that they can actually
perform the necessary steps to remediate
a risk.
Third, we actually provide a workbench.
Where users, security analysts and the SOC team
members can collaborate on a given area
we call that an incident workbench.
It is actually supercharged by
Charlotte AI, providing insights at
regular intervals at the right point
of time, providing insights, suggestions
and recommendations of how to remediate
the risk.
And
all of this is built on top of
AI powered Fusiona platform
which allows you to automate
your responses within CrowdStrike
and outside using integrations,
agentic workflows,
playbooks, and case management.
So to summarize, basically,
we have a unified platform.
We focus on bringing the right data
instead of quantity. We focus on
quality and relevance.
We actually have an
AI powered
threat investigation workflow which makes
the life of a security analyst
much more simpler and easier so that they can
focus on the right alerts.
Now you don't have to take my word for that. We
actually have evidences because
over thousands of large customers
across different industries,
whether it's healthcare, whether it is
tech or manufacturing, have actually
leveraged the capabilities of Nexgen within 1
year of our launch and have transformed
their sock. They're not simply replacing
the tools,
they're actually consolidating
their stack.
The security stack, they are eliminating
point tools, and
they are able to use the AI
built into our platform to
actually empower the security analyst.
So, let's look at some more stats
to just cement what I just stated.
Based on the analysis of all our existing
install base, what we have observed
is that our CrowdStrike customers
are able to consolidate over 15
plus tools
and have a standardized security
stack,
making it seamless for the security users
and soft operations to execute.
What we have also observed is we have been
able to reduce false positives by 95%.
We have been able to ensure
that security analysts are focusing
on the most critical alerts needed
for their organizations.
And most importantly, it is built
at a speed and scale that
is needed for today's time and for the future.
In fact, the statistics that I have here,
which says 11 petabytes a day,
is pretty old. We are growing on
a day to day basis, and today we have crossed 20
petabytes a day.
The same is also actually
um Uh,
for example, not only have the statistics,
uh, uh,
support my assertion, but what we have also
seen that industry has recognized
these aspects also.
We have been named as a leader within a year in
Giga's Sem radar report.
We have been also awarded the Innovation
Innovators Award, and we've been already
in a visionary quadrant in Magic,
uh, Gartner's magic quadrant this year.
So basically,
it summarizes the benefits of Falcon Nction SIM.
Now you may be actually thinking and
wondering how is it relevant for
AWS customers and what did we do differently.
What the capabilities that I just described
about Falcon Nexction SIM is relevant for
every CrowdStrike customers.
But what we did by partnering
with AWS is to actually build
an experience curated for the AWS
users.
So, we are going to elaborate in more detail with
demos about it, but let me start with some
critical use cases.
So what are we trying to solve here?
So one of the key challenges, which I assume most of
you would agree is that
actually uh is a challenge that you may be facing
today is first,
fragmented tools.
So this is not specific to just enterprise customers.
We have observed this with startups and small
customers,
uh, SMBs where you end up having
multiple tools. You have a tool for endpoint, you have
one for cloud security, you may have
one for identity and so forth.
You need to work across all of them.
So that that introduces additional latency
and overhead for every security analyst.
Next,
limited context, the big picture
problem.
Most of the tools actually lack the necessary
context needed for a security analyst
to make the right decision and take action.
What do I mean, what do I mean by that?
So let's take an example. So whenever there is an
incident, there is an alert, we would like to
understand the assets related to
that particular event,
who's the owner,
what a sensitive data is actually.
Either stored in that particular asset or
linked to it,
what is this will allow us to understand the
impact of the possible threat.
That information is not available in traditional
sense. All solutions are point solutions that we
have. Third, the systems
are disconnected.
The security signals are not correlated
across domain and requires manual analysis.
So it's, it's like piecing a
puzzle every time you see an alert because you need to
figure out
if an alert in cloud and identity are
related to each other or not, and user needs to do this
manually. This all leads
to delayed response,
increased mean time to respond and detect.
So what we ideally need is to move
away from a fragmented security
to an integrated security.
So instead of having multiple tools, you need
a unified solution, a platform
which brings all these tools together.
Instead of doing manual analysis, we
need automated detection and correlation
where security signals from different
domains are correlated
out of the box.
And we need a system which can actually
add the context needed
for security analysts to do the investigation.
And streamlined response
and response at speed is what is
needed for an ideal solution to work.
So, a lot of theory.
A lot of concepts, but it was important to
set the context so that you understand what is the
problem that we are trying to solve.
Now let's actually see what we have done differently
to address this use case specifically for
AWS customers.
So we have the Falcon Xion SIM.
Built for enterprises,
we have partnered with AWS to make sure that
it can be enabled for SMEs and
startups seamlessly and
integrated into AWS services.
In a simplified manner which
removes any manual intervention,
provides automation
such that you can actually start seeing value
within minutes of subscription.
You see the data coming in, triggering detections
in a matter of minutes.
As part of this, what we have done is integrated into
the AWS Cloud trade,
security hub, and guard duty to begin with.
We launched this offering on
first of December here at reinvent.
We'll go into the details of the technical aspects. Jen
will be actually going into the details of what
we did at the background to make all of this
work. But at Short, what
we are able to do is, as soon as you
configure or subscribe to file
Connection SIM,
we have services built in to
integrate into these AWS services
and bring in real-time
alerts from your guard duty, cloud
trail, and security hub,
automatically detect
and Uh, uh,
and
show the alerts in your detection console,
respond to those triggers automatically.
All of that done in minutes.
I will skip the technical details and
let Jen go into the details,
but let's
see how this particular solution
will actually work in a real
world example.
So let's take an example of a threat actor
by the name Curly Spider.
Uh, specializing in
finance and e-crimes.
So basically their motto and uh is
very similar to the scattered spider, uh,
or the, I would say the tactics are very similar
to the uh scattered spider. What
they do actually is rely on phishing.
Very sophisticated campaigns to get credentials.
It all starts from there.
Once they gain initial access,
they create persistence by creating
new users, create, uh, launching a VM,
uh, downloading necessary tools, all looking
as legitimate.
Now if this is a scenario that is happening in your cloud
environment, let's say AWS,
how does this solution help you detect that?
So as you can see, there are multiple services
in play. AWS already has
necessary detections in place in different
aspects. Cloud trail, for example, would
detect unusual login patterns.
Guard duty is going to detect a
Suspicious
privilege escalation. So whenever
the threat actor tried to create an IM profile
with admin privileges, it will detect, trigger
an alert.
And similarly, security hub would detect any misconfigurations
or scenarios where
there are overly permissive network
access rules.
So these alerts are already coming from AWS
services into NextGen SIM
in near real-time manner.
At the same time,
Falcon modules are also able
to detect other
signals, for example, other scenarios. For
example, Nexgen SIM would generate
an alert for unusual RMM activity.
So whenever it sees an RM tool activity
in
in a node which is suspicious, it is going to
generate an alert.
Similarly, it generates an alert for any data exfiltration
pattern that it sees
which is attempted by the threat actor,
and also generates an alert for any
curl download operations.
The interesting part is it is already
taking response actions
as soon as it sees this behavior, but I'll get
into it. But before doing that,
all of these alerts came from different services,
but NextGen SIM is able to correlate all
of them as
a single threat activity,
assign it to a single case.
Use Charlotte AI to provide a summarized
view of what that means,
recommendations of what steps you need to take
to mitigate that,
and also trigger any automated
response actions to stop these threat
actors. For example, it will remove or
restrict the access of the user that was
created.
Isolate the VM that was generated
which was provisioned. All of these actions will be
automatically triggered by the fusion
saw response action.
So this is what we are launching
here, where
we have an completely automated solution
which is able to correlate alerts
from AWS,
from Falcon modules, and any other
third party modules and give you a
complete picture.
So let's actually see this
in a demo in real action.
So we'll take the same example that I talked
about. We're using a recorded demo, so I'll just
voice over it.
So we have Curly Spider who has already gained
access, and they have actually
uh uh
logged into the control plane, created a
new user.
Uh, they generated SSS
keypads and they also provisioned a VM
and also created a new user
for that VM with admin privileges.
So as soon as all of these operations are done, out
of the box integrations in Nextgen SIM
will bring in all the necessary security
signals from all the
required AWS services.
And will be able to detect all the
activities
and the API activities
and correlate all of them together. For example,
there is an out of the box detection which will
trigger an alert on the suspicious
excess privilege activity the
user performed.
It will also identify.
The EC2 operation that was performed.
And all of these are correlated
because it has the necessary context. It is able
to identify the detection that happened
at the cloud and identity
and correlate them at real time and
generate a detection. And as soon as it does,
it automatically triggers
a preconfigured response workflow
which will take the necessary actions to stop
the breach
by restricting the access and
stopping the VM from creating.
Charlotte AI at the same time provides all the
necessary insights and summary
for the analyst to work
on and perform additional
investigation. It will provide all the associated asset
information, it provides recommendation that the
user can follow.
It is also very easy for the security analysts
to perform the investigation right here at
the Workbench. So this,
so they can select any entity and actually
go and look at every security
event associated with that.
The solution also comes with out of the box
detection rules and dashboard that provides
you a complete unified view of all the activities,
all API
uh queries or API
invocation that is happening in the system.
So AWS and Falcon Nixion
seem together with this integration is able
to. Perform continuous
cloud detection and response as
a continuous operation
and is able to detect and
remediate
within seconds, in near real time.
So that's a solution that we are
proposing and uh pre uh
launching here and is available for customers
to actually benefit from.
So with that, we'll go into the details of
how this is all made possible and we'll welcome
Jen to share more details.
You might be wondering
how did we make this easy.
So 6 months ago
when, um, we proposed this
to the CrowdStrike team of,
you know, what we want to do is make SIM easy
and the problem was that SIM isn't easy,
but what if we could make it easy,
uh, because at AWS we
really understand.
How to really automate and simplify
the onboarding of AWS
organizations and AWS accounts and resources.
If we take that and integrate
it with
how what CrowdStrike's really good
at, which is threat detection and response,
and we marry those together, I
really believe that we can make SIM
easy and that's what we've launched.
And so what I'm gonna do today is talk a
little bit more for the existing customers
of CrowdStrike,
how we made that easy for you within
the Falcon console,
and then I'll take a step back for that and actually
explain what we launched on November 19th
that makes that happen.
And then I'm going to talk about for new customers,
how you discover it, how that integrates
with AWS Security Hub,
then how that integrates with Marketplace,
and if you haven't used the CrowdStrike console
and you're brand new to CrowdStrike,
how we make that onboarding experience
easy through the AWS Marketplace
so you don't have to start by learning
the the Falcon console,
but you can actually start
by deploying. And then it will pivot you right
into the Falcon console and show
you how to make use of that data.
And more importantly,
AI investigator is part of that. So
if you
or your team are new to
incident response or, uh, or an
analyst team, so maybe you have some cloud sec
ops team members who aren't necessarily analysts,
it gives you a really good way to enable
them to understand what they're seeing and
what next steps they should take.
So how did we make that easier? How
did we make that simplification journey
easier for, uh, the
existing CrowdStrike customers? Well,
within the Falcon console,
uh, there is a Quick Start
for AWS.
And so what this is, is it's a, um,
inside of the data connectors page,
there is a button
that says Quick Start for AWS.
And when you click that, that's going to take you into an
experience that shows you cloud trail, guard
duty,
um, and security hub. But
for those of you who maybe are a CrowdStrike customer
NextGen Sim, but you felt very overwhelmed,
uh, by onboarding AWS because
the truth is it can be a little difficult
because our best practice
is to have a multi-account structure.
And with that, we have AWS organizations.
So for a security team
that maybe isn't
trained in AWS, it can be really, really
challenging to figure out,
well, how do I connect? Where do I connect
that to, and what's the data that I need.
And so for that, we made that easy
by giving you a button that says, connect
my AWS organization to the management
account. You provide that management
account information.
And then with that, it's going to then
connect to AWS and start
to pull in that information and do that automated
asset discovery of the AWS
organization for security analysts
that aren't that well versed in AWS.
And a key part to make that happen
is the service
that we delivered in November 19th,
which is AWS IAM
temporary delegated permissions
managed by partners.
And what this does is when you click
that button and you provide your AWS account
number for your management account,
that will actually, uh, send a message
to the
delegated administrator for
the AWS management account
requesting permission
to add a read-only role
so that the Falcon platform can
understand where is Cloudtrail deployed.
If I have guard duty or security hub
deployed,
what AWS account is that deployed in?
Which regions is it deployed in?
Have I consolidated to a single region
for a security hub so I have a home region?
All of these questions would normally
take 3 to 6 months of
your security team
talking to your cloud ops team to create
a plan
in order to do this deployment.
And so trying to remove that friction
is what we really wanted to make happen
when we provided this IM
delegated temporary permission. Now this
doesn't mean you're giving CrowdStrike the permission
to add roles whenever they like.
It's only
a permission for the next, when the administrator
approves it for 120
seconds for them to actually initiate
the request that then comes back and
actually triggers the cloud formation
template stack sets to actually get
deployed into your account.
And what that does is it really makes sure you have the visibility
to understand what was deployed,
and they can actually look at that.
But then if ever you want to look
back in time, it's in that account where it was
deployed, what was deployed, and how
it was deployed.
And this is the demo.
Yes.
So in this example is
inside of the NextGenim when you first log on,
and you see that on here,
these are the number of detections.
And when you actually first log into
Falcon Xion, I mean you've deployed.
And you're a new customer,
um, it will actually have a link that tells you more
about the documentation,
just logging in.
And this is the next GEM onboarding guide
that tells you detail. All of this would be
available inside of the Falcon
console.
Actually explains
in detail with all the documentation
and videos to follow along
so that you can understand how to do detection and
response triage, set up workflows,
um, set up automation.
Um, and then there are a number of additional quick
start guides, which are also more
about the different Falcon cloud, um, Falcon modules
that you can use.
But in this example here, what I'm going to go
over to is.
Going to the data connections
page.
Getting there. As you can see there are a lot of components
to the next gen SEM.
And here you can see the actual
um. Quick start
tab.
Sorting it by.
Cloud trail,
and you can see this cloud trail and guard duty
itself. Clicking
on the Quick Start
on here, you can see that it's already connected to
one active cloud trail and it shows another
one disactive,
as well as all of the active, uh, guard
duty and security hub connectors that
are automatically deployed.
At any point in time, you can disable,
um, a, uh,
one of the data connectors and it's immediately disabled.
No further data is coming in,
uh, to NextGen SIM.
But then when I want to turn on,
say, uh, an inactive service after,
um, asset discovery,
it actually issues a temporary
permission request.
And when you click on it, it actually
sends a redirect link. This is what the
administrator would see inside of
the IAM console.
You can see someone has issued a temporary delegation
request,
and when they actually click that, it'll actually show
them what permissions they're
requesting
and what's the temporary permission
that they're requesting that's only going to be for
the 120
minutes that it was enabled.
So that they can actually create the role, what role they
were creating it in, what account it was creating
in, as well as the permission boundary
so it doesn't allow runaway access. Now each
of these,
um, temporary permission requests
have been submitted by, um, ISV
vendors in advance for.
Security review by AWS with
the appropriate permission boundaries.
So from that perspective, we're checking
to make sure that these permission requests,
um, do not, are not overly permissive.
So you're not necessarily giving ISV vendors
access that is inappropriate.
Then once that permission request has been,
um, approved, it'll actually
show that it's deployed. These are the number of different
states that that status can show so you
can understand if
the admin rejected
that request. You can also understand if
it timed out so you can reissue it. And
then once it's active, you'll actually show
on that page at the bottom the active
going from deployed to active state
again. So
for new customers, uh, that do not
use the Falcon console,
we have a number of ways you can find that. Number
one is through the AWS marketplace,
but also inside of AWS
security hub in the management
section,
uh, there is an integrations
tab, and within that there is a tile
for, um, the Falcon NextGen
SIM for AWS.
Inside of Marketplace,
um, it will, when you click on that, we'll send you
to the same page with AWS Marketplace
for which you can then deploy.
Now this is the demo of that end to
end. So say you're an AWS
security hub and you go to that management
section.
Inside of that management section you could type
CrowdStrike or Falcon.
You can click purchase or configure.
And that will actually take you to
the marketplace page.
You can click,
uh, and, and review that page,
click View purchase options.
And once you click the view purchase options, you'll
actually see the metrics you'll be charged for
for consumption.
There you can see it's um per gigabyte
for ingestion and then there's
also some cloud workload um.
Protection that Rob will go into further.
Uh, once you accept that and subscribe,
um, and you click on set up my account,
this is the page of what will actually begin
the verifying the permissions that you would need to
deploy this in the marketplace,
uh, for
initially, it would be deployed out of the
management account. I remind you that because it needs
to be the head of the organization.
And then, um, it'll actually pivot you
to the Falcon page to actually register,
uh, as a new customer. Once you provide your
information on this page,
um, it will actually submit that
to CrowdStrike,
um, and then when CrowdStrike, they'll
start to auto provision your SID
for you, your customer ID.
And then it will, uh, send you emails
telling you the status of that.
And so here's an example of the emails. First,
you're gonna get an email from the AW or your
billing contact. We'll get an
email from um
AWS Marketplace saying that you have subscribed.
You'll then get a welcome email
from CrowdStrike as a pay as you go
customer, and then you'll get an activation
link. Once you click on that activation
link, um, you will go ahead and,
um, provide a password,
an MFA for your account,
and then, um, it will log
you in.
Now, once you complete those portions
and you refresh the bottom of the page, it'll
actually, uh, take you to the autoconfigure
component.
Now, it's gonna default to the region you're
in when you're deploying this. Now you can
specify a different region you want it to run in.
But by default, it's gonna detect the region that you're
in. um, it's also gonna detect
all of the cloud trails that you have configured, selecting
your organization with management events.
Now, the reason we want to provide this to CrowdStrike
is because
management events inside Cloud Trail
is every API action
that happens
inside of AWS. So if I want to know when
someone's provisioning something, if I want
to know when someone's creating something new, when
someone changes something,
it's always going to get recorded in cloud trail
first,
um, coming across the event bus. And so
getting that information as soon as I can
over to my SEM
so I can start analyzing that quickly is really
important. And then if
the customer has a guard duty
or security hub enabled,
that's set up so it deploys those via Amazon
Event Bridge
so that those events as they're
occurring and being logged
to the default event bus within AWS
across your organization,
that is going to be sent immediately put on the
event bus for CrowdStrike,
uh, SIM so that it picks that up and can
respond in real time.
Now once the integration is complete, this
takes about 10 to 15 minutes.
Um, you have a link where you can click on and
it'll take you to the stack sets in cloud
formation so you can see everything that was
deployed,
how it was deployed, and for here
when it comes to guard duty and security
hub,
it's not that. Changing the configuration or
modifying the configuration of any of
those, but we're just determining which
AWS account
that that might be delegated to, as
well as the region or regions it's
deployed into so that we can deploy these
event Amazon event bridge
rules
so that we can start sending those.
And then once you go back, you can also,
uh, click on the launch crotch strike.
And that will take you to the login page to the data
connections. And within data connections,
once again, going here, you can see,
um, the cloud trails that were
enabled.
As well as those that it might have discovered later,
the same thing,
uh, with guard duty and security hub.
And with that, talking a little bit
more about the pay as you go, it's Rob.
Thank you. Thanks, Jen.
Many, most of you are already
CrowdStrike customers. Thank you very much,
um, but there are folks
here who are not CrowdStrike customers and,
um.
You know, we, we wanted to make all
of this easier
for the AWS customers, for people who are
just starting to onboard.
Now everybody here who's an AWS
customer, like why did you move
to AWS in the first place? Why did you start building
there? Why did you migrate?
It's a lot of different reasons, but at the end of the
day, AWS allows you
to move more quickly,
simplifies your operational burden,
um.
You're able to render your infrastructure
as code. You're able to
scale out, scale in. You're
able to launch in other regions.
That ability to move quickly
is a differentiator for for
companies today.
Now If you don't
have security it's very,
very difficult to get all of those benefits
because your security team is gonna slow you down at every
step. You're probably the securities team,
security team, you know what I'm talking about.
Um, if there is not that security
in place, how do you know that these
developers who are building infrastructure are
actually applying security best
practices and even if they
are.
Um, uh,
you know, how do you know that those,
um, those controls are being deployed,
uh, at scale across your whole
organization? Now when security
is in place and it is able
to automatically scale in
response to
um uh resource
uh provisioning events.
And you know that it is being uniformly
uh deployed across your environment.
In those situations, security is a
catalyst then you're able to move faster,
able to grow faster, able to
get all of the benefits of
what you have done in AWS.
So we wanted to make the, the, the,
the Falcon platform and we, we've
been partnering with AWS for years
and we have over 110
integrations.
So we've been, we've been building hard
and fast to make it really, uh,
valuable for AWS customers.
So we realized we like in order
to reach customers who are not
ready to sign an annual contract.
In order to match the, the,
the universal common
procurement method at AWS, which
is to say consumption billing or pay
as you go,
we realized how important it was to offer
that to, uh, to AWS
customers now at launch.
Our pay as you go offering
is intended for new customers.
If you were already an AWS customer
and, and you wanna try out any of these new
capabilities, then,
you know, we, we recommend talking to your,
to your sales rep.
If you're a new customer, you can get
started in minutes with no
spend commitments.
You are charged literally.
Um, as Jen said before,
uh, per gigabyte ingested
for NGSIM,
and when we say per gigabyte ingested,
that is a flat fee. It's not,
OK,
it's, uh, it's a gig here, and then
there's some additional costs, you know, for retention,
additional costs for all of your queries
and dashboards. No, it's a, a single
flat fee
for your, your data ingestion.
And when we talk about how easy we
made it to ingest AWS data,
um, the simplification wizards.
You can ingest any data that NGSI
supports. And we have,
um, I think approximately 200,
um, data connectors built for a
wide range of data sources.
So we have per gig pricing
for NGSIM and it always includes 13
month retention.
We also include in the same listing,
Falcon cloud security runtime. Now you've
heard, you know about the Falcon sensor.
Falcon cloud security run time is that,
that sensor component that deploys
in EC2 instances and container
environments or Fargate.
And it also includes container image
assessment
um at at every phase
in the um in the software
development life cycle so
something that can run on the
um uh on the on the
uh IDE of the developer station
or in a CICD pipeline or even
registry
um red um ECR registration
we can do it all in all of those places
and then you can build policy off
of the findings
of that image assessment.
So the benefit of this for customers is
again, instead of going through a multi-month
sales cycle, you can deploy in
minutes.
Jen was showing you the workflow
through
uh through Marketplace.
Um, once
customers submit that,
that input form data,
essentially we, we need your email address
because that's how we allocate permissions.
It, it, it takes the, the
fastest we've seen and probably on average
is about 10 to 15 minutes for all
of the provisioning. So we wanna get you
protecting your workloads as quickly as possible.
Again, there are no spend commitments
and we provide very transparent
public pricing.
Um, to allow you to align your spend
with consumption.
Now what is Falcon cloud security? Now,
um, if you're familiar with this module,
we sell it in different flavors. There's really
the proactive component and there's
the cloud runtime component. Cloud runtime
component is really
more reactive, so the sensors running
on your workloads, watching all of
the events that are happening in,
in, in your, on your host in
your system.
Um, we take all of that
information and the sensors themselves
are able to, uh, are
able to process about 92%
of everything that comes through there and
make a positive determination about
whether,
um, uh, some,
uh, suspicious activity might be malicious
and if it is. Malicious
you can create your own
uh prevention rules that will
that will stop
the the attack in progress
without any additional effort
even out of the box we're doing that, but you
have the ability
to really tighten those rules based
upon your particular workload and environment.
Um,
on the proactive side
we're, we're collecting information
about your, you know, CSPM,
basically your cloud security posture management.
And uh and that entails
pulling in cloud trail
through um
through Event bridge so in near real time
we can
see if
there are any indicators of an active attack
and we could look at your your your
configuration of your AWS services
and make sure that they are configured
according to security best practices. Proactive
security includes a lot more than that, including
data security posture management, AI
security posture management, and so on.
So in this release.
Cloud security,
uh, runtime protection
that you see on the right
in future release will be including
proactive security, but just to give you an idea
about what Falcon cloud security actually
is. Um,
We, we have a lot of studies since
we've been releasing this. We talked to customers
about, um, uh,
the actual outcomes that they've experienced.
Um, we have a team,
uh, that does business value assessments
so that we can provide some metrics
around the improvements that, um,
that companies of
similar sizes are able to see so you
can see things like a 98%
reduction in critical vulnerabilities on the
proactive side.
Um, on the, on the, on the
runtime side, 89%
faster cloud detection and response.
And when you think about a number
like that in the context of
how fast these attacks proceed,
as Minoj mentioned before, on
average 48 minutes.
From initial
access in, in, uh,
before the attacker moves laterally,
51 seconds before the attacker
can move laterally is the fastest
that we've seen before. It's imperative
that, uh, teams are able to move quickly
and we do that again through that automated
capability that the sensor is able
to do all by itself.
Um, and we're able to do it through,
um,
the implementation of agentic workflows
and,
um, in capabilities
that we provide again that
allow you to accelerate
these, um.
These investigations.
Um, so just to summarize,
um, Falcon Cloud security runtime
protection, what are the capabilities that we're offering?
Thread intel and thread hunting is
really, uh, underpins everything we
do across the whole platform. So
we're tracking adversary activity.
We track over 250
adversaries, so we understand
exactly the, the, the
industry. Or organizations that
they typically target as well
as their very specific
um uh tools tactics and
practices so that we can anticipate
what they're likely to do and when we
start to see a series of behaviors
we can figure out what they're probably gonna
do next so that we can identify and anticipate
and block
um uh those kinds of attacks.
Cloud workload protection again that's
the, the sensors deployed on the workloads
themselves that not only can take that
independent action but take
um uh that that that
are also taking events and sending them up
to the cloud for further analysis
anything that's going on that we don't
understand, we're not sure if it's an attack we haven't
seen it, we don't know that it's positive.
Um, you know, OK or neutral, we'll
send that up to the cloud and in milliseconds
we can return a response
so that, um, that your sensor can
take appropriate action.
Um, cloud detection response,
um, is a, a new and developing
capability. This was one of our
announcements.
Um, cloud detection response is that we're able
to take all of the telemetry
across the entire cloud estate
and we can determine
through that overall context and
through. Um, uh, subtle
signals whether there's an actual attack
in progress and what we just uh
what we just announced in the last few
days that we're gonna be pulling into.
Um, the, it, it, it
will be part of pay as you go,
you know, within the next couple of months
is real-time cloud detection and
response where we're able to take that cloud
trail stream
and correlate it with other signals
we may have to say,
you know, it's not just that we see
this particular one thing happening
in cloud trail.
It's that we see a chain of behaviors
that of in and of themselves
are indicative of an attack and um
Curly Spider I think was a really good example
of of uh of of the kind
of signals where we would take all
all that cloud information and show you
that there's an attack in progress and then
automate a response that you can
set up the automation
uh in advance.
Um, and again, Falcon Overwatch and Complete.
Um, you move to the cloud, maybe you've
just done a migration,
maybe your security team is,
uh, a little bit stretched or just getting up
to speed with the cloud,
um, you can accelerate your migration,
um, or if you have a small team
that you don't wanna,
um, you know, try to.
Um, staff a team for,
uh, 24/7 365
operations. We provide a
portfolio of managed services
including managed detection and response. That's
Falcon Complete,
managed thread hunting, that's Falcon Overwatch.
If you purchase complete Overwatch is included,
but you can purchase Overwatch separately.
Why is Overwatch important?
Right? There's a lot of data here.
NGSIM next gen SEM
is a place to correlate that data. We
provide those rules,
um, we provide the correlation rules,
we provide the automation,
but if you want us to manage that,
we can do that for you. If you want us to do
the, the, the, the threat hunting
correlating all the signals, we can do that
for you. Um,
at launch, uh, we have,
um,
as Jen described, we
have created data on boarding simplification.
The data on boarding process can really slow
companies down, so we wanted to make that
easy so you can start getting value
as quickly as possible.
Now in a later phase of our pay as
you go, uh, strategy and roadmap,
we are planning to add that
level of automation,
um, so post pay go purchase, you'll be able to roll right
into
multi-account or wide sensor deployment.
Um, now this is that that
capability is not in
marketplace today,
but what we,
what we announced
2 2+ years
back is a partnership with AWS
where we built, um, a
set of cloud formation templates,
um, called AWS Built in.
That enables that multi-account
organization-wide deployment of sensors using
uh SSM Systems Manager.
Uh, we have a published uh distributor
package you can create those automations,
um, uh, deployment on
EKS and other container environments,
um, uh, multi-account
ECR registration, multi-region multi-count
ECR registration.
Um, all of these exist and
the documentation that Jen was showing before,
uh, also includes, um, how
to use these features
and one of the things that I'll say is this
is continuous protection.
Um,
if when you deploy these, um, these
templates in cloud formation, we also
have them in terraform,
uh, they not only protect the
resources that you already have deployed.
But they also, um,
they also deploy lambda functions and so on
and, and, uh, event bridge rules that
will detect
when you provision new
AWS resources and then will
automatically protect those resources.
So going back to what I said before,
just protecting your resources in that
single point of time is not enough. You
need to know that it is continuous
deployment.
Um, based upon
when you are deploying your resources
and of course if you scale them back
then you are no longer charged for
those sensors, only when only those
running sensors. So to look briefly
at what we have here, um, the first one
is, uh, account registration
that's something that's gonna come more into
play when we release the proactive component.
This already exists in our console.
Um, the rest of them are runtime
Falcon Cloud security runtime features, so,
um, EC2 instance protection,
um, you know, again
with, uh, systems manager. Systems
Manager itself will see when a
new,
uh, when a new EC2 instance,
um,
uh, goes online and will automatically deploy
the sensor at that time again cross region
cross account.
Um, container registry assessments if
you want to do that container assessment,
we recommend that you do. It's a very powerful
tool. Um, you can register
all of your ECR, uh,
uh, repositories across all of your
accounts inside of an organization,
uh, again in, in just a single
template deployment.
And then finally we have a Falcon operator,
um, uh, deployment methodology
that will enable you to deploy
the operator once in an in
an EKS cluster and it will deploy
the Falcon sensor and we have
a Falcon Kubernetes admission controller
that allows you to create admission
policies
for those container images
that um that we have done the assessment
on. Um,
in that assessment we're looking for different vulnerabilities
or misconfigurations, and you can set
your own threshold determine whether you wanna
just prevent those or
to alert on them and so on.
And for those of you who are building your own
um uh generative or agentic
AI capabilities,
um,
so many of the tools used in,
in, in building these applications
and models.
Um, training models and so on
are, are containerized, and
many people pull those containers off of
public repositories.
This is one of the, the primary,
uh, sources of,
uh, of malicious software,
um, malicious tampering that we see
in these, uh, in, you know, as a,
as a, as a large AI security
threat, so, um.
Sending all of those images
through that kind of container, uh, image
assessment and then being able to set policy
is gonna be uh a critical part of
your, your integrated your integrated
AI strategy as well.
Um
If you'd like to get started, if you're
not already a CrowdStrike customer,
um,
uh, we have a QR code here on the left.
Again, you can get started in minutes.
Um, like I said before,
that single listing includes both Falcon Cloud
Security and NGSIM. You could use any mix of
those products that's relevant to you.
Like Minoj mentioned before, if
you use Falcon Cloud Security with NGSIM,
the storage of that Falcon Cloud security
data is all free storage.
Um, you can learn more about, um,
uh.
CrowdStrike Falcon for AWS. I'm not sure how
that's different, but then the other one,
CrowdStrike Falcon NexG SIM for AWS
through AWS Marketplace. Are these all the same?
No, they're not.
OK. The first is a site where
they can learn about AWS and,
uh, Falcon integrations. OK.
And then the other is a blog on,
um, how to deploy Cross Strike Falcon
NextG SIM step by step.
Thank you for spelling that out.
Um, thank you very much. We're, we're.